good morning everyone good afternoon
good evening depending on where you are
in the world and thank you for joining
us for this webinar with the 1 how to
study for the Salesforce exam and crack
it on the first try well we'll see how
close we get to that but certainly there
are tips and tricks to cracking studying
and training for and cracking the
Salesforce exam and our our friend Ahmed
is the person to tell you about it
Salesforce as popularity is soaring
across all industries and there is an
urgent need for professionals with
specialized training to get maximum
value out of Salesforce tools and that's
why the number of professionals who want
to get certified as developers and
admins and Salesforce is surging but
training for the exam and taking it
successfully can be a real challenge so
today Ahmed is here to share some best
tips and tricks for prepping for the
certification exam as well as insights
into the value Salesforce training for
your career if you're not familiar with
Ahmed he has more than 17 years of
experience as an IT program and project
manager and nine years as a trainer he's
an expert facilitator and corporate
behavioral trainer and a sales and
service cloud consultant as well very
qualified gentlemen we're happy to have
him here to guide us through this but
before we get started I just want to
make sure everybody is hearing me okay
and I want to familiarize you with your
dashboard really quickly so take a look
at your GoToWebinar dashboard and you'll
find a little tool there called
questions but lets you type in things
for us to see go ahead and type hello in
there if you would just say hello to on
it and let him know that you're happy
that he's here and you're looking
forward to hearing what he's got to say
fantastic mark thank you I'm happy to
see you here with us today and Sidhant
is here a few other folks saying hello
in the system that's great that tells me
you can hear me so that's a good thing
that means I'm not just speaking into
the darkness sometimes GoToWebinar takes
us by surprise tells me I'm talking but
I'm not really talking
thank you for joining us keep an eye on
that questions module that is your best
friend as we're going through the
presentation so if you have questions
about what you're hearing and you'd like
Komets to go back and cover some
previous points or to expand on some
things more specifically to your
situation go ahead and type it into the
question module and what we'll do is at
the end of the presentation which should
run about 30 minutes or so then we will
loop back around and we'll do a proper
Q&A where we'll go through your
questions and try to cover as many as we
possibly can if you hear something
really brilliant that you want to share
with your friends to make them all
jealous that you're here and they're not
you can do that you can live tweet you
can post on your Facebook feed you can
go to LinkedIn and paste the share
whatever it is that you're hearing you
can use the hashtag SL webinars if you'd
like let folks know where you are and
all the awesome things that you're
learning and they'll be jealous and
maybe they'll join us here with you next
time that's probably all you want to
hear from me you can hear to learn from
a real expert so I'm going to turn this
over to my friend on it and let him
guide you through the mysteries of
Salesforce thank you so much I'm it for
being here yes absolutely it's all yours
my friend oh thank you very much thank
you
I do read out the names and you know
most of the name sound as if you know
what are you trained you guys and I'm
not sure whether that's true or not but
anyways most of the names quit sound
quite familiar to me
well well come on board once again guys
my name is Hamid thauvin and you know I
have a small brief intro to be done I
hope you guys are able to see the screen
come through is my audio and video all
clear to you can you keys to I guess in
the chat window to confirm it to me head
to the chat window
yeah the chat window with the right
place I think you're typing it in the
questions pan all right that's fine
thanks chip okay thank you guys thank
you very much I'm just like you know
quick ego about gauging on before I
could get started off with my you know
small intro I would like to gauge on as
exactly you know what what is the type
of audience are not dealing in with air
so if you guys are not
having a microphone or you have some
audio issues Bob you can let me know
I'll just try to unmute you one anytime
I'll start from the top and go bottom
I'm gonna move sit down sit down
I'm using you Siddarth Keaney Amy oh
okay that's fine sit on I think you know
there's a lot of noise which is coming
in from the other side you can speak up
we want to talk hey I said and I can
hear you some decent music playing in
the background
alright so I'm gonna go and mute use it
on that's okay sit down you can even the
meanwhile go for typing in your brief
intro let me move on quickly onto the
next part is friend Raj Raj can you hear
me out
yes yes I can hear you loud and clear
how are you doing today mate
alright so killing us quickly go about
briefing about was what you've been
doing so far have you been already train
has been training have been training
what is it
I deal with things to stay okay it's
Maya Great Britain I know there is a
reason I - aha okay oh that's very good
but you know thank you well welcome on
board once again you brat so I'm going
to go ahead with Brian hey Brian can you
hear me out
Brian could you hear me out yes yeah hi
Brian
it's going pretty good about you oh
great thanks for asking
Brian cookie you know briefed about
y'all so what have you been doing so far
basically what I did is I took this
simply learn three-week waltz and admin
and Dev and right now I'm working for a
company as a project manager in part of
the newly started with them and part of
the arrangement was is that I get some
hands-on with the development portion of
this and doing some projects getting the
swing of it learning how to listen in
and the the qualification call so when a
customer says to me have this need the
the channel screen right now and I know
how to do that but I don't know what
that relates to is it a you know a work
world whatever it might be translate
that into the functionality there of
this take time okay that's really good
to me uh Brian so was it pina excuse me
who was the trainer Celestine Brian
scarf oh okay all right great great good
to hear on that thank you Brian thanks
for joining us all right let's go on to
mark hey muck I think I know this name
mark could you hear me I'm sorry I think
I don't need a response mark I reckon I
think you have some are you sure you
don't have the mic mark can you hear me
out all right I'm gonna move on from
mark mark you can probably you know pin
down your brief intro last but not least
we got the Lunt hate the lump can you
hear me out
yeah me hey Dylan how's it going very
good how are you I'm doing good sir
thank you go ahead brief me about
yourself
I work as a dotnet developer looking for
career change a little louder please
yeah go ahead I'm working as a dotnet
develop and looking for a career change
in alright okay fantastic
so uh you been working in the dusty
since how long
Oh 10 years fantastic welcome onboard
Allah good to hear from you alright so I
know more what chasm is one of the you
know the guys who would start up the
sessions he's what he was working with
simply no guys I'm so sorry about the
bad throat I mean it's thumb up the with
the bad weather here can you apologize
okay so I'm gonna picking it up brief
you all about myself this is me you know
I've been in the - you feel almost like
17 plus years now and almost like 9 plus
years working as a trainer and also you
know nine and a half plus into the
Salesforce I've seen CSS grow from Zim's
to nothing from nothing to almost you
know becoming everything so I've seen it
grow through the roughs and drafts all
throughout where it was you know almost
like the cane packs it's only been a
decade you know once it started you know
making a presence be felt since once
they are not the pioneers in the world
on the crm domain you know they they're
definitely been struck by the new
technologies that have been making a lot
of waves in the market where they
started you know doing venture or they
started venturing into the world of
ceará now just to kick start off you
know they did you know what the you know
starters in the world of crm domain
where they took cloud computing very
seriously and you know started providing
services in the context to SAS fast and
ayah so what do we mean by SAS Fox and
is that you know just really go about
doing a small brief intro about you know
what this is all about and then probably
you know come back to my concluding of
the inter part and then you know start
off the sessions so you know Salesforce
you know well I have me necessarily the
same so suffice some time as I said and
it's been a way you know acquired a lot
of certifications from them
and prior to this I have been into
dotnet I have been into my console
technologies done a lot of enterprise
level development work to talk about and
the capacity of a job role but I do
Julie is you know play I I am working as
a Technical Architect
slash the solution architect and I you
know I'm a developer by Nature and
painful you know guide people around
train people around guide people around
or you know providing my expertise
whatever I could as an SME with the best
of the knowledge that I could bring
across the table so uh thanks what I I
would suggest you know you you since you
didn't already given me your brief
introduction and I have most of it
already identified i what you know kick
start off with a small foundation we
laid on ourselves talking about ever the
three major tenets that we journey talk
in the reams of having to be discovered
on the cloud where we would have done be
identified as stars fasteners now
Salesforce CRM is not just the serum I
mean they started up there there they
venture into the CRM domain vertical
with the SFA as a Salesforce automated
apps but you but today you look at them
you know they they have a complete
platform framework me you know the
architectural approach that has been
enriched into the reams of having a
platform come through as an offering
that you can think of building up any
kind of a solution or any custom built
solution to go about extending and you
know that is where it open ups it opens
up the very platform to allow for the
integration to come through with any
disparate third-party systems seamlessly
so this is total this is a total win-win
situation for many of you you know
wherever you be working in your legacy
systems video legacy systems in your
legacy technologies you know your
outdated technologies you know people
come to me you will see the background
where you know rational background you
know they come to me where you know much
how did it technologies where you know
it's it's given them a lot of ray of
hope to take up Salesforce and build it
up as a primary skill set now this is
where I would guide you in the into the
direction as to how it can really
benefit you Salesforce CRM went up
with the lights of the major a giant
such as you know Microsoft's here and
Dynamics SAP you talk about Siebel
products Oracle products whatnot you
know Salesforce has taken leaps and
bounds it just not died it's just not
the virtue of you know which is saying
it but you know it's actually if you
under the in it reading into be habit of
reading through the things on the
internet you know go and check out the
doctor reporter for me the forest rated
for Gartner has placed in for CN I mean
to the first francha Quadrant for the
last three consecutive years when it
comes to meeting of the customer ecstasy
so that's that's definitely you know
big-time heat bounds change over a
change in a paradigm shift over in the
change thought process what has led to
the largest user dr. Billy rate across
the globe with the lowest TCO total cost
of ownership what generally used to take
almost like a running number of months
would only take running number of or
probably couple of weeks to have the
deployment or the development build
across the deployment within within the
or across the different arms be carried
on and there are different there's also
flexibility in account of having to do
it and you can you know Bachelor have
you can you know time it or you could
write scripts to automate the complete
process into it now this is where
Salesforce CRM has led to a lot of
demand in the market for Salesforce
professional there's a lot of resource
scarcity believe me
whether you talk about the US market
Europe which is email or the AIPAC you
know I've seen it all and I mean
training about almost strange like an
army of Salesforce resources till now
and I've seen it all the growth hasn't
stopped yet why Salesforce they're
they're like a thinking company you know
they're wearing they're thinking hard
and they are in the very event of having
to roll out three major releases they do
three major releases in a year where did
these the way do they get the meat from
well they have a site called ideas or
salesforce.com adage encourage people
like you and me to go and you know
testify the feature sets what they have
as an offering for the different suite
of products what they come through under
the hood Salesforce where
people like you and me would go and
evaluate their products and bill
proposed as a blessed as we practice
what would come through what needs to be
what needs to come through on the very
product line and this is what is taken
as a vote against on other ideas or
salesforce.com where the the idea which
gets a maximum number of words
definitely gets taken care of seriously
by the product management team and you
would definitely get to see that come
through in the next release so I mean
it's it's a product which has not
developed it's not being developed by
Salesforce it's a product which has been
developed by people like you and me
further likelihood of having to meet up
the ends what you and me would be facing
up the real time or the ground floor
level zero so this is this is what is
one of the biggest differentiators which
has really stood by and you know has
made them have the presence we filled in
the market so to take you through what I
would have well I'm not gonna talk I'm
not gonna deep dive into the very card
code technical competencies you would
definitely you know have that
flexibility you go through while you sit
through the training modules and there
are different training modules that you
can take up from simpler and they're the
pioneers in the indie industry to bring
up the very use case driven with the
practical hands-on light project
implementers implementations that would
take you through the entire course where
of having the implementations go through
for out-of-the-box functionality or
being any net integrated custom
development solutions what has to be and
what has to come through under the sales
or via the services now the very trick
or rather it is let me put it this way
you know just sitting through the
training would not release uh Feist you
really have to you know have a benchmark
and these benchmarks are identified by
the certifications that you could
definitely go about gauging on against
yourself or rather you know acquiring
these certifications while you sit
through them so how do you make sure
that you know you know you've got a pass
through the certificates the first
important thing the first most make sure
that you do you understand what are you
getting input are you gonna be planning
in to get into the shoes of an
administrator into the technical side of
the implementations or are you somebody
who's gonna be getting into the shoes of
a developer throughout the programmatic
side of the implementations or somebody
you know who's technification of kind of
a profile who's very both the hats
together now this is very important why
because you would then be knowing the
fact as to what is the right training
module that you would like to get
started with well there are modules
which are rated from basic to
intermediate to intermediate or advanced
you can surely go about picking on them
and recording you know you can sit
through the very certifications which
are aligned according to them simply
learned will definitely you know bring
in a lot of expertise around that area
and will help you to cherry-pick on
these forces as equal oh sorry guys so
it's something you know similar to the
lines where what you have is a train
head from Salesforce you know they
provide you the trail head to go on a
certain topic from basic to intermediate
and then to advanced so it's in a manner
which is similar and now pretty much
similar in fashion to it but when you
think from the lines of googling around
the different sources or going and set
you through the trail heads it's an
ocean of information out there you don't
know what is the starting point what is
the me what is the mid path how you
gonna you know make yourself sail
through it this is where you know the
SMEs would the SME from simply learned
would come into play and they would
bring out the best of the breed
available in the market as trainers and
they will help Ukraine on the track
which will walk you through sequentially
having acquired the training is just the
tip of the iceberg believe me it's a
start of your relationship with
Salesforce CRM as a product that you are
as a other technology that you would as
a product that you'd be using in your
real time scenarios or is a real time
projects or as a technology that you
will be coding in for and whatnot you
will be doing everything in everything
now this is where you need to make sure
the
the training modules that you acquire go
step by step where they are aligned to
certain certifications which you should
plan to take up over a period of time
now certifications they add star to your
uniform if you think on the lines of
just going into the market or launching
yourself into the market where sales
force training under gone from me that
will not really help you have to you
know plan your resume you roll out you
have to you know build your resume is on
the lines where you know you have your
projects incorporated on the sales force
you know gauge yourself with a good
understanding and also have the
certifications be acquired now how do
you go about making sure that you know
you go and acquire certification well
I'll tell you there are a lot of tips
and tricks there is no hard and fast
rule to anybody who's writing the exam
should take one approach versus not the
other one well they could be any
permutation combination of approaches
that could be taken up it will all boil
down to the maximum number of a seconds
go cut spending out and in whatever
approach you take should be the best
well what does it mean it simply means
that you should be a regular attendee to
the very developer or the success
community which has a lot of technical
threads
a technical material white paper staff
whatnot that could really help you gauge
or probably get hold of the the new
things or the new incumbents which are
making a lot of wave in the industry not
only that many people generally go about
sharing of the solution what to to the
very recurring problems that could come
through as a design pattern that would
be very very instrumental to you while
you go about understanding in how you
could go about incorporating it at your
a to resolve a resolve a problem that
would have been in stayed for quite some
time and that would be a differentiator
for you having said the
this would also lead you to prepare the
grounds for your certification because
in the exam you do not know that the 60
multiple-choice questions are you gonna
get there are different sets that are
revolving which is the set that you're
gonna get through or probably whether
the questions in the set are gonna be
the same the next time you go in a pair
or bigger eyes get changed so it is
always a good practice to gauge your
understanding from the practical point
of view having to hear or the
storyboards or the user stories which
are putting through by many of the
participants or the attendees or you
know consultants like you and me who
have taken census as a prime minister
this will give you the varying hat and
this will really you know give you the
thinking hat and you can start thinking
on the lines and what you get gained up
for it you know once you get into the
groove of thinking aloud on account of
different practical implementations
believe me there will be a time that
would come where you won't be you know a
contributor rather than just you know
sitting there and a hearing or people so
you will start contributing to the
threads one important aspect is that any
practical use case that you come through
or a question that you come through for
the online you know the papers or any
Google material that you have you must
make sure that you practically implement
and see the resultant they could always
be a possibility that there would be
many a-times
answers which are very close in
proximity to marking the result a result
an answer so don't get confused the best
way to resolve would be first rule of
elimination second you would need to
Google around it to make sure that you
have a good technical know-how available
on it
what would have matched up with your
understanding third practically go about
implementing it the more you do it the
better of you would be at the end of it
last but not the least having taken up
the training having identified the
trainer instructor
the best of the breed and I define what
what do you need to sit through made
sure that you are well supported by the
back-office team where you have to drive
a short to conclude the very project
implementations which are rolled out to
you not only in the class with the
solutions which are being talked about
but also go about making yourself an
active participant in these simply
learns online discussion forums which is
simply talk that's another you know a
discussion forum that really bring in a
lot of value add and while you go about
attending it or probably you know being
a contributor there believe me I have
you know come through many such
questions that I get asked and as an SME
I have to go about answering them and
without so before I could go about
answering them you know I have to you
know sometimes go and drill down into
the very nitty-gritty of how the things
are actually moving inside the
architecture and you know make sure that
the answer that I give is up to the mark
and definitely you know would help the
participant yeah have a good
understanding and give me a five-star
rating that's definitely out there so I
mean it's more about practicing other
things rather than just you know taking
up the theoretical knowledge it's it's
the functional understanding which has
to marry the technical core
implementations what would make a
difference for you in a real in a real
sense in a long term even when you know
you get down to the wire of having to
acquire a certain or get yourself
absorbed in a certain job you would be
you know tempted to do a lot of
implementations at your end and you
should do that why because you know
that's gonna add like an art lead to
your you know it's really gonna give you
a lot of advantage and beta H to you
while you go about you know talking to
somebody as a client who would talk to
you in a wavelength which would be well
grasped by you and you can definitely
compliment them you know by talking them
in a similar manner where you could
propose then what you would know off as
an implementation that could come to
seamlessly under three years of
Salesforce and these are what is
available as out of the box if there's
nothing something which is available as
out of the box you could definitely need
a go about looking at some
the point of solution that could be well
dated or integrated within the reams of
Salesforce that's really good engaged
that's really gonna help you gauge more
understanding and you know level you out
with your certification scales you know
you you're talking skills are you
communication while you talk to somebody
you know and you know persuade the end
clients so all in all this is this is
the very gist of the things that I
wanted to talk about well I would
definitely encourage you know you guys
to raise questions and whatever you may
have I would like to you know take this
up more collaboratively rather than you
know just keep talking it out myself
I mean I'm nobody to give you the gal
you already have it and believe me or
not I mean I am here to learn and that's
what the attitude has to be with you
with each one of you so I would
encourage chip can you hear me up yes
sir okay fantastic
so chip I would definitely want you to
you know let people speak up or speak
out their questions and I would like to
take up the real stuff rather than just
keep talking of the theoretical stuff so
let me let me let me face the music I do
invite people to go ahead and type into
the question module there if you've got
specific questions about training and
into Salesforce and with regard to
choosing a path and making a career
change we'd love to be able to do court
sort of a and asked me anything if you
would where you can get some guidance to
your specific situation and if you've
got a microphone and you want us to open
up your microphone so you can talk
directly of course indicate that in your
question and we can open your microphone
up as well as you heard earlier though
sometimes that's a challenge in the
meantime while we're what we're doing
that I see Siddhartha's as who did not
have a microphone has let us know that
Siddhanta is pursuing a thirty-year beat
back and who's enrolled in big data and
hadoop development is interested in
cloud so a wide variety of technical
interests from
Mountain and interested in adding some
expertise in Salesforce to the mix I
imagine I meet that there are
organizations that are moving from other
systems to Salesforce they might be
using ASAP or some of the other large
platforms and I imagine that as as
Salesforce becomes more and more
predominant we see a lot of migration in
organizations is there an opportunity
there for Salesforce professionals to
really help companies with that
migration to specialize in the
challenges that come with switching CRM
platforms and it's and if so do you have
any idea which platforms people are
moving from is it helpful for a
Salesforce professional to have
experience also instantly other
platforms absolutely you know you'd be
surprised that I did three or four
batches I don't recall what is the count
from McAfee and I had a had the very
opportunity to work with some of the
very senior Siebel consultants with the
company where they were getting trained
why because there were a couple of
projects that were lined up with them
that reckon migration of data that
happened that needed to be happen from
their very respective systems what
they've been using in the past into the
reams of Salesforce so things have
started moving out I am going into the
Salesforce so not only this I have heard
you know people working on technologies
like mainframes you know they are
putting themselves into Salesforce so
there's a lot of space you know being
created ok now when I say the space is
getting created what does it really mean
you know they could be a possibility
that you could either have a complete
migration of one system legacy system be
done into the very new incumbents and
the Salesforce or you could even think
about having your legacy system still be
followed where you would allow for some
kind of integration to go seamlessly for
the bi-directional flow of data from one
system to the other for example there
was one of the projects or
where until the connectors were built
directly to allow Salesforce to connect
to the SAP we had to incorporate a
middle tier which was I via the
informatica on cloud and having the
scenes for speed 2 informatica and then
informatica talked to the SAP would
really get gave us a lot of background
check on wood gave us a lot of grounds
to understand one of the different
technologies other than Salesforce that
could be leveraged where they could come
as an offering as Sasso could even be a
pass you talk about you know a java
application which is hosted on a Heroku
environment which allows a seamless
integration for the flow of data both by
direction come from an endpoint which
could either be yourself implemented or
probably could be a sequel server and
the end of it all right would that help
absolutely a little bit of an audio drop
out on my end and I was thanking you and
it was it was not going anywhere this is
one of the things I love about
GoToWebinar that's it's it's really I
think we're seeing that opportunities
it's just huge for this migration as a
Salesforce becomes more and more
understandable has also integrated
AdWords conversion into Salesforce I
know within the past year is that
becoming more critical for people it is
now becoming a large part of the
necessary knowledge and skill set inside
Salesforce to understand Adwords and PPC
in the context of behavior tracking and
conversion tracking and so forth within
the Salesforce environment when people
be well advised to have some
understanding of Adwords and maybe even
be certified there fantastic very good
question you asked me a question and I'm
gonna give you more than what you asked
for
now hear me out it's not just the Google
ad was integrated into Salesforce you
talk about any of the email of marketing
strategies or the designs what you could
think of as an third-party
implementations or applications that
would have been there I'm pretty sure I
mean if you guys know about market or
web marketer or probably you know part
in
there have been a complete suite of
different email and marketing management
system that allow for a seamless
integration that would than are already
built out as applications are many of
the IOC's and published on the very app
exchange that's one well okay I'm gonna
cut this short
alright that was the answer I mean I
hope that would have helped you know
there are so many parallel providers and
various kinds of services that integrate
well with Salesforce and I think that
pardon me it's true that one does not
need to be expert in all of those other
parallel services and tool sets
necessarily but at least understand them
well enough to know which questions to
ask and what research to do to be able
to integrate them well with a with the
Salesforce installation yeah you sound
like I appreciate you stepping in today
and hosting with us but you sound like
you're really suffering from your throat
should we consider cutting our session
short today or you okay to keep going no
no I think I can keep going that's fine
you know well I think you glass of water
now so very good so a preview of
cooperation thank you very much so as
one is choosing their path through
Salesforce training and deciding what
direction their career is going to take
within that can you talk a little more
about the difference between being a
Salesforce admin versus and developer
absolutely so you know you could live
with Salesforce
being an administrator or being in the
declarer side of the implementation but
not more than three to four years after
which you would need or you would feel
the urge to move into the development
side why because until unless you've
seen the things actually how they move
behind the scenes are the
implementations that go through
decorator and at times you would be
urged to you know even have the
programmatic interfaces be built up why
because there are certain limitations as
the equation tells me in Salesforce 85%
of the time
you'll be able to implement the certain
decoratively all through click-throughs
but 50% is the integration side or the
development what would come through if
the form of writing epics and this is
where if you can't win the heart of
having to go through both the admin and
the Decker the admin and the development
side you know you can be somebody in the
shoes of becoming or technical architect
or if not a functional and techno
functional roles that would play the
role of a solution architect very good
thank you
I am also curious about what other kinds
of training would be most complementary
to Salesforce to help make one a more
rounded provider of service if it would
be something like you know project
management certification agile and ITIL
training or any particular coding
languages other other concurrent or
complementary kinds of training or
certifications that someone might pursue
besides the Salesforce specific
certification well this the answer the
question will be you know somewhat
related to the first question that you
asked you talked about any technology
anything that comes on the web 2.0
whether be integrating in JavaScript so
now as a new incumbent in the market
which are the jQuery frameworks like you
know the bootstrap the angularjs a node
backbone whatnot which has actually led
to which has actually let Salesforce to
you know take that the very lightening
design system to come into play is all
orchestrated from the same thing so you
know you need to know all these
technologies where it would go
hand-in-hand together to give you the
best of the solutions that could be
incorporated because in today's world
why do you know cell you will be will
still since you would be you know
building up a solution on the cloud is
all gonna be in a disconnected
environment you need to make a lot of
asynchronous calls all the call-outs
that would need to go through where the
API is this is where having a good
understanding of all these technologies
would really come as a plus plus
yeah I obviously the the broader the
skillset the more employable and
valuable you are to any organization so
absolutely broadening your your ability
their Salesforce is not a cheap install
this is a platform that really is priced
for large organizations and enterprise
customers so I imagine most of the
opportunities are within the enterprise
space I imagine there are no
opportunities really in SMB so is this
is this a career path that makes itself
appropriate to work as a private
contractor or are most of the
opportunity is going to be on in-house
teams with large organizations and
enterprise customers oh well you know
I've seen it both to be honest you know
I've seen it both way because you know
it may vary it we totally vary when
you're working for a product based
company you know I generally would work
you would be you would be wanted to work
as an FP where you know contraction
works would generally come out in space
where where you are an SME and you
really want to you know add value
bringing our value to the team of
developers who would have nothing as a
knowledge on the play so both both the
both both the arrangements work equally
good very good yeah I know that there
are plenty of folks particularly
probably in that migration space there
might be more more room for independent
contractors to help folks that are
moving from one platform to another you
mentioned that the certification test
once once you've gone through your
simply learned training and you've
trained against the current book of
knowledge with Salesforce and you're
prepared to go take your Salesforce
certification test you mentioned you
mentioned that it's a multiple-choice
test and of course they rotate the set
of questions so they're never the same
set of questions at the end of the test
I imagine you you could with a score
does your score play into your
competitiveness competitiveness in the
job market and do employers see that do
they ask about is it like you know we
have the SATs
for preparing for higher education and
and people will ask you what was your
SAT quotes for the people asked about
what your score was on salesforce visit
make you more or less no not really I
mean nobody would ask you that score and
you don't get this goal and you end up
getting a pass or a fail that's it
ah so you don't even really know whether
you're in the 10th percentile or the
30th percentile you know you know you
don't get to know that that's true and
then you recertify how often do you need
to recertify with salesforce or is it a
lifetime
very good question so you know as I said
you know CN suppose they're generally in
the practice of having three major
releases done in a year with every
release that they do you have to if
you've already taken up certificates to
be there you have to sit through the
maintenance exams and these minions
exams will come through against the roll
the new release notes that would be
rolled out to you they're not pretty
difficult they're very simple I mean you
just got to you know make yourself well
acquainted with the release notes which
come up every now and then 3/8 rice in a
year so you know it comes in a big time
I mean it's not I would not call it as a
big name pain for me but it's a big time
learning for me I mean I've taken almost
like six certifications 6 into 3 1880
maintenance exams is what I have to sit
through in a year
wow that's that's a lot of training but
that ensures that people who do have a
current certification are really
up-to-date on the very latest changes to
the system and and requirements that are
going to be relevant to to their
employers so now given that what do we
know about the advantage that the
certification obviously there's certain
you mentioned earlier there's
certification and there's hands-on
practical knowledge right there's
there's really doing the work so if I'm
in the job market and I'm looking for an
opportunity with an organization and I'm
up against people who have a lot of
hands-on training but no certification
or I'm that person I'm up against people
who have certifications and I don't have
a cert but I have a lot of experience
working in Salesforce because I just
learned it
in my last job what what are employers
looking for they are they obviously in a
perfect world they're looking probably
for a balance of those two things but
what advance what what distinctive
managed is having the actual having sat
for and passed the certification exam
give us in the marketplace very good
question so remember you know I said
that having to get certified would let
me would be like something like adding a
star to your uniform so when when
employers are looking for recruitment
you know the journey look out for
candidates was certified white because
they would be able to build the team
pyramid of certified sales force
professionals and would be able to you
know portray the same to be to their
respective clients and that gives in a
lot of bth which is the reason why
they're looking for certified
professionals and having to certify is
definitely a must
sorry yes having that certification is
going to be the the the thing that
really indicates your dedication to the
skill set your dedication to keeping
your your professional skills up to date
so I would imagine that if I had my
choice as an employer I would look for
somebody who had some some skills and
some some experience as well as having a
certification if you're just starting
out now when when when folks take the
course from simply learn they're gonna
get the opportunity to do some hands-on
write practice projects right so they
can they can if they don't have any
other kind of professional real life
portfolio they've got those projects
that they can point at with an employer
and say I was able to do this but do you
recommend that people also early in
their career maybe look for
opportunities to volunteer their
services to build a portfolio of
projects maybe working with local
nonprofits or startups that as a
consultant to just sort of get their
hands in the tool and so see when you
have to start up a career and you know
that you know you don't have anything as
a you know a real time project done in
Salesforce or anything and everything
that comes your way you
pick up so I mean I have done it and
believe me
success to anyone's career path would
lie in the core in the in the variety of
different prod projects that he would go
about doing up and that would really you
know open up the platform understanding
and also you know give you a platform
where a launchpad where you can you know
start gauging more experience and go
about you know talking it about go about
flaunting about tell the world Duluth is
asking specifically with regard to the
simply learn training what are the what
are the projects like that you get to
work on inside the training so you would
have to admin declarative side
implementations a related project and do
development you know the programmatic
side implementation projects and then
there will be a holistic overview of the
projects clubbed together you know an
end to end implementation that can come
through for all the learnings are you
required that's very thorough yeah so
you get something on on both sides of
the both the admin and the you mentioned
the value of simply learns simply talk
for him as a place for people to ask
questions and get to know other other
learners and other professionals are
there any other specific industry events
or conferences or any special blogs you
like to follow that that help keep
people up to date if they're working
within the industry we do be honest you
couldn't definitely Google out anything
and everything but the only three places
that I generally go out is the developer
community the success community and you
know simply talk which is simply learns
you know technical forum where there is
a lot of technical discussion you know
many of the SMEs go party were talking
about things are probably proposing
solutions which you know really come in
pretty handy I have a great learning out
there that's and when you mention the
first things you mean those are on the
salesforce community right on the sales
side what I'm talking about is a
developer community in the success
community and this is something which is
accessible to anybody and everybody yeah
once you get your developer organ census
which is the virtualized workspace
environment agree
you will have a quick handy access to it
so you know everybody has access to it
fantastic
I'm gonna take over the screen here for
just a second I usually do this before
we even start the Q&A but we were we had
we were so excited to get into the
conversation that I didn't do it but I'm
taking over the screen for just a second
here for those of you who are still on
with us if you'd like to talk with
someone that simply learned about taking
a course and getting some training in
Salesforce learning more about what it's
like if you'd like to maybe see what the
back end of the learning platform looks
and feels like if you'd like to get a
little guidance on which because there
are several Salesforce certification
trainings available to get a little
guidance as to which one might be
appropriate for you and for your goals
and your business and your career we're
happy to have somebody talk with you
there's no obligation but it never hurts
to talk directly with somebody and get a
little guidance to make the right choice
so if you're interested you can take the
appropriate box there and as I mentioned
a lot of the folks who are on here with
us are already simply learned members
and you're already familiar with the
trainings we have available so you don't
worry about it you don't have to take
the box but if you're new to us and
you'd like to learn more please do I'm
only going to leave this up for a second
because I don't like to do a whole lot
of a lot of selling on these webinars we
want to we want to keep it to actionable
learning but in the count of three I'm
going to get rid of this so if you're
interested this is your chance to have
someone get a hold of you and two and
one thank you so much for indulging me
my little contractual obligation there
to represent the company while we're
doing this I'm also going to share some
links into the chat module so everybody
who's on here with us if you would take
a look at the chat module I am going to
share some links here make this make
sure this goes to the whole audience
there we go so these are some links to
some places on the simply learned site
that you might find helpful one of them
of course is is a listing of Salesforce
related courses that are available the
other resources link also gives you
access to some white papers and articles
and ebooks and things like that as well
as
more upcoming webinars that our
Salesforce related so you can take a
look at that and the last link is drops
you into our career edge section of our
site where all of the resources across
all specialties are available for you to
dig around and find some white papers
and some articles and some resources on
whatever it is you're interested in
learning Salesforce and beyond so Donna
had mentioned interested in the cloud in
is studying big data and hadoop right
now so Sudan if you want more articles
and and things that are related to your
areas of interest you'll find those
there as well
we are against the end of our hour here
and I invite anybody who has any last
questions to go ahead and drop them into
the question module otherwise Amit I
just want to say thank you for stepping
in and picking up where our other SME
had to had to step away today and you
did a fine job of taking over and
sharing all your information with
especially with a sore throat yeah
that's very much appreciated and you
know making a more interactive session
and you know I really like that and if
you have more questions yes please do
both them to me I would love to answer
them absolutely I I've reached the end
of the questions that I had listed so as
I say I think that we've answered
everybody's questions that is in
attendance so we get we get to drop out
seven minutes early today but thank you
again I mean I hope we'll work together
again soon and thank you to everybody
for joining us taking time out of your
day or your evening if it's the middle
of the night where you are then extra
special thank yous for your commitment
to showing up and beyond that we will
see you next time and have a terrific
rest of your day take care everybody bye
bye just blew me
you